some of you some of you make sure that
me giving a similar talk about this live
earlier in this in this institute
but uh hopefully not too many people
so uh okay so so you will you will find
that uh what i talk about
is very related to uh the talks of uh
both sleeve white and uh transfingo
uh that came from a different angle so
uh
so it's also so so what i'm trying to so
the problem i'm trying to understand
is very similar to what brian is talking
about it's about is related to this
holography so uh i won't give any
review of uh holography
or this idiot crt duality
again this is working yeah so
but maybe i will
just explain a few words as a general
motivation
actually let me write down the reference
before uh
my pet died so i can't find the archive
number of my paper
anyway i would do that so so uh
so the so basically uh
we know from uh from this uh works from
starting from spring theory uh there is
this holloward
duality which
which at the beginning it was known as
the idea clt
so
so it's a duality so it's a saying that
two theory which looks very different
are actually the same series and later
we understand that
uh it's not only restricted to conformal
field series which are mapped to some
special
geometries in gravity but
more generally it's uh it can be
generalized to other
spaces in general
there is some gravity theory in d plus
one dimension
and there is a corresponding
quantum antibody system
or non-gravity system which means uh we
have a hubris space and
everything uh as we are familiar with
and then that's indeed dimensions and
then in general uh
this this kind of uh division is known
to occur in some special series
and there is some reason that uh uh we
as condescending physicists are
interested in this because it seems that
this is not something very specific for
for some uh like only very special
series but there's some general
physical reason behind this duality uh
which which is related to this
renormalization group
so the general future uh
that was proposed was you can understand
this uh emergency dimension as a
energy scale so as brain already
drawn earlier you can introduce this
extra dimension
and then think that as if it's an energy
scale of this
uh this antibody system so think of this
as a for example
one plus one dimensional system then uh
then roughly speaking uh
it's like you describe the uh
renormalization group then there is this
uh
normalization group equation and that's
sort of like
the equation of motion for the bulk
theory
so so these are just uh some ways to
help us to understand why
there is such a duality i'm not going to
use any of these
by assumptions or i'm not going to use
anything
about this gravity so now the question
is what's the best way we can understand
this
uh this duality more precisely
and what i'm what i will talk about
today is i'm trying to propose a very
concrete procedure
to do this duality uh which may be
different from what is already known
but at least it's something that that
start from things we understand
which means this side and then try to
explicitly mapped to the other side so
uh so basically you uh
start from this uh d-dimensional
antibody
system and then i try to construct this
mapping let's go here called
holographic mapping
and then the other side should be a
quantum
gravity which uh i will call it quantum
geometry
because i will try to understand this in
some
simple geometrical quantities so so this
is basically the same kind of arrow as
the brain drawn
like you start from cubist which means
anybody's system
to some quantum geometry but you will
see there are some
different uh structure coming in here
so uh so to
to do this method then uh our purpose is
now
i'm given a many body state which may be
very simple
which which may be a free free from your
state or something
that that's very simple here and then
given this state i'm trying to read out
some
some information about the geometry that
the system live on
so this is very different from uh neural
approaching
the cft where you uh you already have a
well defined gravitational theory here
and you take some semiconductor limit
and go this way
so here we try to read all the geometry
from
anybody's state so to do that uh
i would like to before going to the
detail i would like to
describe this uh
this approach in two basic principles
so
two very simple uh thoughts about uh
what the quantum geometry should
should look like in you know any body
system so the
the first principle is
uh so basically when we think about
geometry then
i i don't know my mathematicians have a
more
advanced way to think about it but what
i will
do is when i usually take the analogy
take the analog
of lima geometry and ask okay what can
we do something like that in the quantum
systems
so then for riemann geometry the key
thing is that you have points in a
manifold and then you define distance
between points
right and this distance uh is given by
uh
the geodetic distance is given by some
magic and then you are
done everything else is uh is a function
of the
metric so so here then in the quantum
system if we want to understand
its geometrical properties then we can
also ask these two questions
about points and the distance between
points
so then we don't know in general how do
i define these things
but there are some general
principles i can i can assume which
seems reasonable to me
so so the first thing is about what do
you mean by points
what's the definition of points in a
quantum system
so so we know in any body system when we
say
we have this real space science so think
about discrete geometry then
the thing about discrete systems so you
have lightest size and then we know what
that means is
my hero space has a direct quadratic
decomposition
right so the hero space is decomposed to
a product of hyperspace on each
side
okay however this is uh uh
this this is not a unique choice
so so if i just give you uh many what
say i give you a mini body system
i i say i give you a thumbnail system
which
looks like this
but i didn't say what is what do i mean
by this i have some label right so the
hamiltonian is a metric
right so i can i can just do
transformations go to different bases
and then say in momentum space it may
look diagonal
and then you can choose some other bases
like the wavelengths you talked about
yesterday which will show up later in
the top
so uh so so you you can choose any basis
and then in any basis you can view it as
if it's uh as if it's real space
right and for any of this basic choice
it gives you
a set of direct quadratic decomposition
and the different decompositions are
related by unitary rotation
in the hebrew space as long as i assume
every side has the same dimensional
herbal space
then they are just related by rotation
uh unitary rotation right
so so so this so okay so the first point
is saying that
uh that the definition of point
corresponds to a choice of direct
quadratic decomposition
and so far the choice seems to be very
arbitrary
but then uh of course we don't i mean uh
we know some
some choices are better than others like
if you choose momentum space and you try
to describe physically momentum space
then what you see is uh say i have a
fermi service and uh
and then everything is occupied here and
vacant outside but then you see physics
is very non-local once you introduce
impurities then there is something that
can be scattered arbitrarily long
distance
in momentum space uh right so so there
is no locality once you introduce
integrity but but in real space in what
we already know as real space
this doesn't happen you have something
that's moving around but if you have an
impurity and it's scattered but the
physics is still local
so so so i would say low quality is what
distinguish
some basis with other basis when you
consider a hamiltonian when you consider
a system
or you consider a family of systems then
the basis which
where the physics is local should be uh
the sort of correct basis where you can
define geometry
so so so but uh how to quantify that
that gives a
that's related to the second point which
is about distance between points
second principle distance between points
so basically what i want to propose is
that we need a
so for every choice of point we need a
way to define distance between points
and if this if the distance you define
seems to be very weird
like uh then then you conclude that this
this is the geometry is very badly
defined and
there's some basis where the geometry is
better defined
so in general again i don't know what's
the most general principle
uh that tells me what is the distance
between points
but uh there is some very general
principle we should
believe which is uh relativity according
to instant
that relativity means that i shouldn't
have
something i shouldn't have a geometry
that's given by hand
from outside this would be some whatever
the distance
is it should be determined by the
physical correlations in the system
i mean if you live in a in some universe
where you have some fields propagating
around
you measure the distance whatever you do
to measure it it's something
some sort of korean function in that
world
right it's a right you don't want
anything uh
at the hand from outside so following
that principle then
it's saying that distance should be a
function of correlation
in the system and if you allow me to be
more
uh specific this may be a assumption but
i would say that the distance between
two points
x and y which are two of these points
is a function of correlation between
these two points
which means it may be correlations of
some unknown function but
some operator but if you consider
all the possible operators inside x
and all the possible arguments inside y
they may be different operators
and you consider the average value of
them and they may also have different
time
yeah are you compressing space or space
time
because i want to start from something
we completely understand which is a
quantum system
so i already have a continuous time yeah
so in this sense
i'm not in a sense
they are not treated equal they are not
treated completely equal footing
so space is something that depends on
the choice of point but i already have a
time direction to start with because i
have a hilbert space
and the hamiltonian and these things so
they're not treated completely
equivalently but
however that doesn't mean that time
direction is uh
is completely given so that the i can
measure
uh distance by correlation also in the
time direction
you will see how that gives you for
example ads space
where where it's not something cross
time where time direction metric
is changing in different locations and i
want to say
that corresponds to the physical fact
that the correlation in time direction
also varies in different locations some
somewhere
locate somewhere the the correlation
lasts longer in time direction somewhere
less shorter
so this impression so the general
principle is
you calculate all possible correlation
functions between the two points
and the distance should be some function
of that
okay so uh so so this
so so these are the the general the
starting point i want to take
and this sounds maybe too abstract but i
know i will make uh i will show
explicitly
uh how i want to realize them and maybe
not the unique way but
there is one way to describe the
geometry in
following these principles so
let's start from something very simple
which is a
free from young in 1d
so let's take this as an example
so
so you can consider some something like
this so i'm drawing this as
like so this is like a fermion hopping
on this chain but i draw it in this
exact way but it's actually just a 1d
chain but this link and this thing has
different hopping
right so so so so now with the half
filling we know the the fermion
has uh so so if you if this two home has
the same
uh the same uh uh strength
then you will have a band like this a
trivial band
and then now if you land if you
introduce this demo addition
in here you will get a folding
so after the folding uh you open the gap
and then your dispersion looks like this
okay so uh
so if i write the hamiltonian in
momentum space in
after the folding is a two band model so
the model looks like
c has two components and then
something like that so then uh
so m is a uh m is a mess
which is given by the alternating the
difference of the two bonds
so so so uh
i will not for now this is just a
illustration of some system which is
massive because
see electrons are electrons they have
skin and polymer
they have a spinning which corresponds
to the two components okay
okay yeah so they don't have a spin
other than that this is this is like
this
c is like a column of see what is
peanuts
yeah c is like that the polymer seeds
right but i mean the oven down actually
gone through these two so so
okay so so so for now we don't need
anything specifically for this model
uh i'm just before we go to more details
of this model
i will say something uh generic
uh about basically we try to
try to propose a way to translate this
into an explicit formula
like distance is some functional
correlation but one function is there
so
uh it should be logarithmic of the
korean function that's what i want to
say yeah
yeah so yeah so now let's first look at
finite mass
okay finite math and then we know for
linear functions
say something like this let's first talk
about space
then current function looks like this
right
let me write it this way yeah so some
constant times
uh exponential decay so equals
yeah so here i contract over them i'm
just taking an example but whatever you
calculate
whatever artificial calculator should
decay it's naturally right
so for a finite for this massive state
so
so then uh this motivated me that if i
want to
define the distance as a function of the
correlation function
and i want to restore the familiar
geometry
that we are familiar with then we simply
reverse this formula
we define the distance to be reside
log minus minus something log
of the correlation function and we call
it cx line
divided by some constant the content is
the maximum
of the correlation so okay
so so now uh if you define this for this
system
uh uh you restore the the other familiar
flat space
in long distance this is only long
distance i simply explode there's only
like sure the genesis
will behave weirdly so your distance
will be strange it should be concerned
that's right slowly
yes i uh yeah so uh
i i will only i mean i will only care
about the long distance behavior
so so basically this is this is
because in general you you can't i mean
in this theory there is only one field
so i can't really distinguish the change
of correlation function
coming from geometry change and the
change of correlation function coming
from
the change of dynamics so basically i
have to just
force this current function to force
this function to have the same
formula and apply it to every different
system
and then you will get the correct
geometry in long distance
and the short distance you guys
something not imaginary
but the key thing the key thing uh what
i want to say here
is that when your system goes to a phase
condition when when the gap closes and m
goes to zero
even the long distance fails right but
also for sure
distance should satisfy this axiom the
distance between two points is
like smaller than that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah for small x minus y small
so when we talk about long distance this
uh this is okay
but the key is here yeah so so i i don't
so the key thing is that
even the long distance fails when you
have finite mass we have zero mass and
that tells you why
you need this holographic duality but
why why it's natural to do this horribly
basically
what what that means is if you live in a
world you will automatically come up
with this higher dimensional description
because this thing fails because because
say you live in this world and then you
you you you develop physics and in the
end you find oh if i use this formula
i get a nice geometry and get riemann
geometry i mean
in this case you have flat flat space
but if you live on a curved
manifold you will give the same formula
you will restore the event geometry
right
so everything looks okay but if one day
you have a phase condition in your world
and then some some formulas become
massless and then you that formula
that that particle happened to be the
one you use to measure your distance
say say we live in a world where photon
is massive and then one day the photon
becomes massless
but we don't know we still use it to
measure distance then uh
what we will find what we find is that
the distance
now will look strange because the
correlation becomes parallel
so the distance will look like your long
distance will look like a log
function right log function of this this
thing which is the euclidean distance
so now you will say okay that's just
maybe maybe i find some gravitational
waves
maybe my magic has changed but actually
that's not what happens
i mean you you if you think more
carefully you'll figure out there's not
just a change of magic
it's not like your space becomes curved
because even if your space become curved
this cannot happen as
as you find out that the distance is
important that the distance must satisfy
the triangle inequality
which means if i have say
let's let's think about the higher
dimensional mandrel for a while in in
the one years a little trivial so
so you have this flat space and then you
have x
y z generically
the uh distance so it should satisfy
d x d smaller or equal to d x y plus d y
z
okay if you use this distance you check
that
it's still true the triangle inequality
is satisfied
however it's always this because the log
function goes like this so if you have
x plus y
you will find that d x y plus d y z is
always bigger
than p i z what that means what does
that mean
is uh if you move the wire around in
your space
there is no point where the wires leaves
on the geodesic
line because if you have a curved space
you still have the elastic line right
now there is a line so you can find the
third point we leave it on that line so
that d x y plus d y z
equals to d x three so so what happened
here is if you have this distance
then this cannot then you cannot find
the geological line anymore
and that tells you that your your
geometry start to become quantum or
strongly fluctuating
you can you have all these different
explanations to it
but uh but anyway uh this tells you that
your geometry uh
is not a remind young giant but this can
be
this problem can be resolved by defining
by defining a new set of points doing a
unitary transformation to a liberal
space
find a new set of bases and in a new set
of bases you'll find that
this equal sign is restored that's
the reason why if we define
length by time it takes to send light
signals for example
which is what we actually do right then
you don't have this problem
then then they start like you already
start from here
start from where you you already have a
world where light is a message
yeah then you you have a different
formula from this obviously that's a
different definition of length like the
time it takes for you to shoot this
fermion
to you and then back to me yeah i think
it's a different definition of length
than
than the decay of the fermion
correlation function that's right but i
think there is a
yeah but then then then if uh i mean
some some other paddle will happen if
you are if your life starts to become
massive i mean basically i'm trying to
say
that if you think about the mass
response as like a face and lean point
then
generically you should define it this
way and then
this is a special point where you see
the geometry
gets different and they emerge the new
dimension but
uh if you always have the massless
particle moving around
i assume there is another way which
tells me that there is some formula
which tells me in this case
it's uh in ordinary case it's flat but
sometimes it will
uh it will become critical and then you
you got something different
but but this is the just in the
massive case i can make it more concrete
yeah
so so this learning like
comparing reason that we insist on the
triangular inequality like comparing
physical reason or something
what i mean is that like it sounds like
your message is that distance is
just um like just our
like mathematical abstraction of a more
profound
like physical reality so but
is there like any reason that if we make
this mathematical abstraction
that that is triangular in politician
code
uh no so i mean i can certainly claim
that uh
i just defined some distance function uh
which doesn't satisfy that or which
satisfy the
inequality but there is no equal sign
and i just call it a different geometry
i mean this is actually a distant space
it's just not the riemann space
so it's so it's totally okay i don't
think there is physical reason why this
is always satisfying
it's just saying that if you find a way
to restore this ordinary distance in a
riemann geometry sense
then we have a sort of semicolonical
geometry description geometry
geological description of the physics in
the system
so it's trying to connect what happened
in your generic system you know critical
system
to what we are more familiar with
doesn't have to but yeah
so so so basically uh
what what happened is okay so now in
this case i'm saying that if you use the
x and y's
that's the same x and y that you're
using in the massive case
you get this weirder distance and then
yeah if
if you can't avoid that maybe maybe you
have to live with it but the interesting
thing is that
we can't actually avoid it by by doing
this mapping and go to a hierarchy space
and then uh so so so i will describe the
mapping but the uh the basic
the reason why it may work is that uh
you can put this side um on the circle
so every side is exactly these two
together so there are four states on
every side but i have two formulas
and then uh then you can define a
unitary mapping
since i'm maybe i will just draw meaning
so you define a uniform mapping
so now
so so what this does is uh it's uh
uh it's a combination of a bunch of uh
tensors
each tensor is actually a unitary
mapping so
so uh you you see a a different version
of this feature from skills
was still drawn there yesterday so you
you have a mapping
that takes two sides in and then
uh takes one side this way and the red
one should be thought as
an arrow going out for the plane so
say i have four states on each side from
your occupied or not
four states on each side then this is a
16 by 16
unitary which maps the two sides here
to two other sides one is this arrow one
is the thing the red thing going out
okay and then the then evolution
continues so in the end
you map all these boundary sides
to uh to the red circles
and you can count the number of red
circles the same as the number of white
of the blue right so so
so uh what
what what you want this marking to do is
when you measure the distance in the new
size
in the red sides which are just a
different way to do decomposition within
the hero space right
because because in the end the whole
thing is it's not a state it's a unitary
it's a
sorry i like to call it and it's a big
unitary matrix in the hebrew space
which matters uh map these sides
into the right sides and then when you
calculate the distance in the red sides
uh the claim is that what i will show
is they look like
hyperbolic space when you have this
critical distance
and that is possible because uh
so that that is a i mean that's a
possible solution to this problem
because there is a sort of a now in this
new basis you define
a geodesic which goes through the bulb
so so basically what happens is if you
have
a point living in the in the hyperbolic
space
then the geodesic actually looks like
this
and it turns out that the distance let
me call this distance which is the
distance in the boundary direction as x
minus y
and then the geodetic distance as t x y
then in long distance this d x y scaled
like log of x minus y
and because of that uh what
looks like a parallel correlation which
means c x y
proportional to some power out what
looks like a power law correlation in
the
boundary actually looks like it's
natural decayed
uh in the bulk so that's why this is
possible
that's why it's possible to interpretate
a capitalist system
correlation behavior of a capitalist
system as a gap
system as a massive system living on a
different geometry which is the
hierarchy geometry
so so so this is the this is the
this is the reason why this may work but
i will
uh i will need to show that that
actually works
so
so now to show that let me define this
mapping more carefully
so now let's focus on one word type here
so so although i'm using the brief
formula example
everything defined by this tensor
everything here these are generic
they can be applied for interacting
systems so you basically you take two
sides
and then you do this unitary mapping
which i call the u
and uh and it gives you two two output
size
and then uh
and then physically what you want to do
is you want this
you want to reorganize the degree of
freedom of these two sides in this way
such that the the right side represent
the high-energy degree of freedom
in this is in the two sides and the blue
side represent the low energy degree of
freedom
so when you consider a free formula free
from your case this is exactly the
wavelength
transformation that steve described
yesterday so
which i actually found out recently that
steve has uh has discovered that uh
last year but i i didn't know you you
you have a
lecture online about it so so uh so
actually this uh this
this mapping uh gives you this
wavelength when you when you apply the
free permian
so so in that sense you can say this
mapping is like
a gen uh at least formally it's a
many body generalization of wavelength
so what you want to do is you want to do
something like a normalization group
but you want to do better than we
normally improve in the sense that
uh in the sense that you don't throw
away anything
so the right thing the right thing is
what you would
throw away if you are doing real space
id you take two sides covers green
and the glue thing is what's supposed to
be important low energy degree of
freedom
and the right thing is whatever you
throw whatever you would have thrown
away if you do id but you don't throw
them away now
you know you do unitary you just split
them and then you take the low energy
you do the idea again
you get some some some
uh operator there and then keep going
so so in the end the box states
represent the degree of freedom on the
boundary
at different energy scales so say these
things in the first circle
represent those with highest energy of
say my fermion my formula has a
bandwidth w
then everything on the first circle is
like the things which
the excitations if you create a fermion
there it's roughly speaking it's like a
fermion with the energy
in this window that's the first layer
and the second layer is like
w over four w over two
and so on so in the momentum space
filter is like
basically if you like
all this half how all these things are
in the first layer
and then you you keep going
yeah so you don't need to read the red
ones right
but they are kind of becoming infinitely
far from everything
no no they are well they are feeling
everywhere in the box
but they are not going to be entangled
they are that's the key thing actually
so so the key thing is that the red dots
in the end contain everything right i'm
just separating them in a different way
but in the end every
all the physical degree freedoms of the
blue are transformers with this new
bases and they are in the direct
so the key thing is that i mean if i'm
doing something like a momentum shell rg
i'm doing this really now locally in
real space then they are then they are
related to tangles
but what happens is if you do this in
the real space way they are actually
entangled and the entitlement
is important for macro plus because i
want to measure the magic
using their correlation so
so so the i mean uh and this is also
related to
the uh to the uh the relation of this
approach to mera
and this is certainly this is certainly
a
development based on era
so based on the idea of mera and also on
the proposal bran earlier
that mira is related with the cft so
this is like
a generalization of these approaches so
so the relation to mira is uh is that if
you
completely ignore the direct product
completely ignore the incumbent of these
red dots
then you get a mirror but although
although here you actually get a very
very
uh baby version of mera which doesn't
have disentanglers
but you can you can introduce these in
angular and still have these red sides
going out
you can introduce say cross coupling of
these two and then you do this
so so in general you can do that but in
any case
uh in any case if you assume
make an assumption that the box state is
completely reproductive of each other
then all the entitlement is captured by
the central network itself
then the state on the boundary is a
mirror state
so you can say in this sense
i'm promoting this uh well i'm
defining a mapping instead of state so
that if i allow the boxes to entangle
with each other
then it can capture more more generic
state
but basically i think the more useful i
mean probably
the the main reason is useful is uh
i mean it may be useful for this purpose
is that it's easier for me to
to read out the geometry by calculating
the correlation function in the box
rather than
rather than just put all the
intelligence in the tensor network and
then try to
read out the geometry from the tensor
network itself it's just a more
constructive way but
by calculating two more functions so
okay so in the
so now uh for free pronoun so now this
this
this mapping uh is generic but in
general it will be very difficult to
calculate correlation functions
because i because say any operator here
is some operator acting on the two sides
and any operator here is something
acting on the four sides so generically
it's very difficult to calculate
correlation in the block for a given
many body system but so so i tried the
three
from your example
okay so in the free formula case uh we
have a very simple choice of the mapping
so because it's really uh i can define
the
mapping by their action on the from your
operators
so the mapping is defined such that say
i have to see
at the first side and the second side
second i didn't write the spin up down
because the mapping
act trivially on the speed so so i take
that
i simply take the boundary line bounding
states
this i called a which we used here and
then
this i call b okay
so so uh this mapping uh
if you when you iterate this uh this
this uh
gives you a definition of all the b's on
on these sites
and then you see that okay the b here
the b fermion here
uh just means the antibonding state of
these two is
basically i have symmetrical function so
e in the first layer
corresponds to so so b diagram in the
first layer create a wheel function
that looks like this right so this is
the hardware blade that steve
talked about usually so you you created
this
this wavelength and then if you iterate
here then this b
is a here plus a here right so let's
call it a1 a2
with a1 plus a2 and a is a symmetric
combination
so you see that b2 in the second layer
is like it involves four size
last class management so in the end the
whole mapping gives you
this wavelength basis which depends on
two
uh depends on two labels so it's b
uh which i call j and where j labels the
horizontal direction and the number of
layers
so so depending on different end they
have different size of the wheel package
which corresponds to
physics in different landscapes
the key thing is that there are the
important properties that they are also
so it's just a new basis to describe the
physics
and once we define this
once we define this mapping then it's
straightforward to
use this proposal to check
what geometry we get in this new basis
so
so now let's first check this for the
critical formula so remember remember so
the key thing is that
now my geometry is determined by a
correlation function which is defined by
the state
so so the mapping only fix the
the the choice of basis it doesn't fix
the state
so i can apply this mapping to different
states like a massive fermion
methodist fermion or finite temperature
i can apply it to different states
which will give me different geometry so
the key
thing is i want to make this
constructive so that
you don't design the geometry by drawing
the central network
even for the same mapping you can get
different jump
so let's check the different states and
uh the first check is
for t equals zero and zero so it's a
it's a critical fermion at zero
temperature
so so you get this uh korean functions
uh which i can uh
uh one thing i i should mention is that
there is actually a particularly nice
coordinate function
which is the mutual information so but
unfortunately it only applies to equal
time correlators
but so basically what happened is i
can't just use single particle
correlation
i can use the speed formula at different
locations
and then calculate this which means that
sum over speed
but you may ask in general if i have a
system which is in writing
then i may not know what operator to
kick here if i pick a wrong operator i
may miss something
maybe the two sides are very correlated
but i don't see them
so to avoid missing that you can
actually define
this is the and you can actually define
this mutual information
which is
we know defined as
the angular difference uh between the
two sides separately and
when you glue them together so this is a
nice quantity because
you know this thing bombed the korean
function so for any operator here and
here
this can give you a upper bound of
correlation connected
which says for any operator
like this
i think this thing found the square of
this time some coefficient
so so basically this make sure that if
you see this mutual information decays
in some way
nothing will decrease slower i mean
everything will decay you know power or
in or faster
so so that means you can define your
distance
uh either by using this coordinate
function
or or you can use mutual information
and when you use neutral animation also
advantages you know what is the maximum
but the maximum is just
two times the maximum entropy of each
side
which is allowed foreign
so so
so so in practice what i use is this
thing
but uh when i go to a different time the
problem is
when i want to know the space time here
space time distance
then when i calculate the correlations
in different
time i don't know how to define
different information i don't know how
to define a bond of correlation like
information this is a uh open question
so so i have to kind of step
back and and calculate correlations of
these kind of things for imaginary time
and i guess something like
something like that and i did it i do
imagine time because
in real time everything is oscillating i
don't know how to take this log
uh and extract the leading exponential
so in the emerging time
i can just uh do the same in the same
way as space
spatial distance i can calculate uh time
distance
in the sense like when your two points
are far away in time that means
they are that means they are less
correlated that means when you are doing
minor time illusion
the fourier function decays very fast
okay so yeah so that entropy inequality
basically amounts to special relativity
right that nothing goes to the other
line
sorry the essential thing is
no no this doesn't assume anything this
is a generic no i'm not saying it
assumes i
think that it's it's equivalent
twice now i mean you can consider
i mean i think what you said is like
there is a
very for any well-defined model there is
always a
faster speed and then nothing can
propagate faster than that
it's a i think there's something like a
leader over the bump
but uh this is no this doesn't require
that
so you are not getting upper bound
on the speed of anything just by
now the speed of the severe of the
that's that's that's given by the state
hamiltonian so that's not in the
definition of the distance
i can apply this to different critical
systems for each physical system there
is a bump
but but it's not i mean that's that's
the specific
for each system yeah so so basically
okay so so now if i apply this to the
to the messless critical formula
what i get is i calculate this
i can calculate the correlation function
of different points
and then check that check whether they
agree with uh uh the identity distance
in the hyperbolic state
in their ideas right right now is the
imaginary time so it's uh of course
so so now we do this for one one
dimensional
ad series so the bulk is two plus one so
the bulk is the ads three
so you calculate the distance and embed
them in area three
and the accuracy inverting is determined
by scaling
in general you can adjust the embedding
but you can check whether
this agrees with es3 and
for example
for example if i calculate say this is
one
one layer here one horizontal layer
there
then you calculate distance between two
points
and then as a function of this
horizontal distance
is a boundary direction distance or the
angle direction here
it's still a log function because the
correlation depends power lock
so when you take a log to get the
distance then it's a log function
but this is as i explained earlier this
is exactly what you expect
in the ids space so this this log
actually is considered
as as linear in the distance in the
ideas
and then when you check the radial
direction like you can
you can take two sides that are going
around the radial direction
and indeed uh
as a function of the layer index so say
i have a
side j in ends layer and side j and plus
amps layer as a function layer index
so when you go you are calculating now
i'm calculating correlations between
degrees with different energy and indeed
you see
this correlation is international decay
so the distance grows linear
so so it's this contract that that this
direction goes parallel this direction
is linear
this thing is the key that tells you the
stock space is higher voltage
which means the parameter grows
differently as a function of radial
resistance
so you have same results for the higher
dimension i mean like a dirac
yeah actually one nice thing about this
mapping which is the simplest the heart
wavelength
is it applies to all the directional
higher dimensions
as long as your hamiltonian looks like
something of sine k
in different directions and one minus
cosine k in different direction
this is such hamiltonian is always on
the fixed point of this uh of this heart
on top of this
from your surface damage yeah you can
apply this to the from your service
yeah so that's that's sort of like you
apply the
ordinary critical from your rd to the to
the
from your service then you use what
you'll see is
the low entity theory is not here the
law of the difficulties doesn't occur
here
but it occurs somewhere in the middle
right
or just no not everywhere somewhere in
the middle
but but it's not pinned down to real
really
sharply at size point because you are
not using more enemies
so yeah yeah so
the the heart wavelets have uh because
of the sharp edges they have all
momentum
and uh so since the if you were if you
were thinking about measuring it with
the correlation bond just
it's just a single particle correlation
function which is diagonal
in momentum and you know the heart
wavelets will always have some sort of
overlap
and then if you get smoother to smooth
the representation with more decent
anglers
then you may get fairly disjoint pieces
of momentous space for the
trouble so it seems like you would get
different distances
yeah that's your choice of the
wavelength that's right yeah actually uh
actually there is sort of something like
that non-conductivity like
if you make this direction more now
local this direction can be more local
yeah so so the different choices
certainly give you different geometry
uh and this is this this is a
saying that uh
like these these concepts of distance
metric these are all not very
environmental concepts
they are they are in gravity theory they
are they are coordinate dependent
so you can so i would like to think the
choice of methane
as like a quantum generalization of
coordinate choice
it's not only cardinal choice it's like
that you choose a classical background
to expand around like when do your
string theory in different classical
backgrounds and presumably the theory is
likely independent but when you expand
around different backgrounds you've got
different low energy series
and they look different but accurately
when you look at spectrum or anything
that's gauging iron
that's actually the same series
so so i think i have a terminator
so uh so i hope to uh
get to the point uh before i get into
late i hope i hope
to get to the point that uh
about the black hole because so one one
thing i like very much
is not this thing that i recovered the
ads space correctly because that's sort
of by design like i do an rg
and by design my my computer is not a
fixed point so scale environments
basically pin down
all the structure here so you get you
just you check that it's still
environment so
in life scale it might be ideas but uh
the natural thing is
now i can apply it to different uh
initial states
and then get different geometry
so so this is like a lattice version of
a cft
and then you can apply it into nice clt
you can uh so this the most interesting
thing will be
applying to finite temperature
so for zero mass but final temperature
uh then
we know the correlation will look
different so if you use the same formula
you get a different geometry in the bond
so so let's
let's study what happens separately for
spatial and time
correlation function so so special
let's look at equal time correlators uh
which tells me the spatial matrix
so we know what happened is in the in
the final temperature
if you calculate current function
between these two wavelengths like this
like
your long distance they will decay
externally right so that means when you
take a log and translate this into
distance
then it's not that that log function
anymore but they become a linear
function
because it restarts it because basically
it looks like a massive state
so so at short distance it's like a
power line but a long distance
crossover to linear that's what happens
when you calculate distance between the
two
okay so now what happens if you
calculate this for different
layers going going into the ir
and what you see is that this external
decay is faster and faster
because for the same temperature the
energy scale of these things are going
down exponentially
so so compared to any scale of these
particles which means like they're
helping
and things the boundary the magical
elements of the hamiltonian in the
origin
your temperature is higher and higher so
what you see is that
say this is like the two points both in
the first layer
and then second layer and so on what you
see is this let the slope become higher
and higher
and actually when you go to infrared
this slope increases exponentially
so uh so
because it increases so quick so i
cannot really at the beginning i can't
really
get that limit very well uh numerically
but uh later so so now now uh
with my student qinghao you had some
calculation
which shows analytically what's the
behavior in that limit
and like with basically you calculate
like two very smooth wavelengths
what's their correlation and what you
see is basically
something very interesting it's like
let's calculate two neighbor size
so d j and uh with j
plus one there's like two sides that are
next to each other
that are like this they're next to each
other
and then for different sorts
for different layers and at a zero
temperature they all have
the same distance right in zero
temperature because scaling
these two has the same distance as these
two so now
if you ask now i can ask what is the
uh the area of each circle
in higher dimension it should be called
area here is parameter
so so you can have something like this
and then you measure this distance and
multiply it by the number of sides
so you have an area
area of the end layer so at the zero
temperature what happens
is when you increase end which means you
go to ir this thing decreases
exponentially
because the number of sides decayed and
then the distance between neighbor size
is the same
but at zero temperature what you see is
that because the two sides
when you go to ir the two sides are so
literally correlated
that when you translate it into distance
they are very far away
so that means so the distance between
two neighbor sides actually increases
naturally
which cancels the exponential decrease
of the number of sites so what you see
is this curve
that saturates to a constant
what does that mean that means that if
you use this distance to
use the correlation to measure distance
and you leave that world you walk around
this circle
you see this circle actually doesn't
shrink to a point
you see your geometry actually looks
like
this rather than the disk
a zero temperature this is a point and
when you have the final temperature
basically your space
has been burned the whole that's
basically what happened
so so okay so so that's a good sign that
tells me that
there is a black hole in the center i
mean that's consistent with the black
hole in the center
but it hasn't tell me that the hole is
black because
it just tells me spatially there is a
hole but uh what's the difference
between black hole and let's say
space terminal in ir which happens in
some cases
so if you give the system a mass that's
one case i started i won't show it here
uh if you uh if you have a finite mass
then
uh your space actually terminates but
your time doesn't terminate your time
is doing normal things so there is just
a spatial boundary in the wall
but what distinguished black hole from
that is you calculate time direction
correlation
so you you have this disk and then you
can calculate say time direction
correlation for
for two two times in the same location
imagine time so now you find the
temperature so everything is periodic in
time
okay so what you see is this this thing
when you translate it into distance
which is the log
of this then as a function of tau it's
going like this and it's periodic in
beta
so okay so now when i move this point
gradually inside
what you see is that this thing decays
slower and slower
which is not surprising because the
energy scale is going down
so anything everything moves very slowly
i mean by the way you can if you do the
calculation in uh
zero temperature this also becomes
slower but
the difference is in zero temperature it
becomes lower in power
level since but here here this becomes
very very very slow
in the finite region here which is
defined by
the region where the energy scale is
much smaller in temperature
so there is a region where your your
energy scale is going down like
a like like suppressed by exponential
factor
and that if that is much smaller than
temperature then you basically are in
the infinite temperature limit
n n is the number of layers going in
next one two three
one two three coming up so what's your
which geometry
uh for for so so basically
uh when you calculate this correlation
function uh in the high temperature
limit
uh you lost the time dependent because
you're already in your temperature it's
nothing
nothing time evolved a lot of space
correlations also changed
yeah is what happens here
yeah the space correlation tells you
that space correction becomes very very
short-lived
so so different sites do not talk to
each other at all
but if you look at their time evolution
they're very slow
so so that's the key which tells you
there is a black hole because the time
directions
uh distance sorry this i'm sorry this is
this is actually the correlation
function
current function doesn't decay which
means when you translate it into decent
the decision doesn't grow
so in in the you in the ultraviolet what
happens is the distance grows
and then and then decays back so this is
basically like time direction in the
circle
so the distance between these two points
grow and come back
and what happens in the infrared is it's
almost do not grow
so the circle the radius of the time
direction circle
shrinks to a point when you approach the
ir
and that's exactly what happens when you
have a black hole like if you do this
rotation of the black hole time to
imaginary time
then the horizon is a point where the
time direction circle shrinks to a point
but basically when you do a rotation of
black hole you are obviously to imagine
time for the reading time you get a
cigar shape
and the circle shrinks here at the
horizon
yeah so this calculation we are doing
with the terminology
so if you are doing between the others
then
you get the same thing in you mean a
different system in a different
that's right yeah so so i don't have a
proof that's
always the case but uh but you see from
this
calculation that there is some reason to
believe this is generic because
uh as long as i mean this is assuming
that you have the right
mapping which do the rd that's the rd
job
which means any operator here is very
low frequency
and the frequency goes down uh when you
go through infrared
as long as that's true then then when
you have a finite temperature
it's always like this part looks very
hot and this car looks cold
because the energy scale is different
the country temperature for the time for
the boundary system temperature is the
same
but because the separation of energy
scale the center part
looks very hot and because it's very hot
then the correlation function
becomes very very short range and that's
the reason why there is a hole
opened up to the center and then there
is this very slow time evolution which
gives you this
time in friendship so this is basically
sorry the red shift
so this is telling you that when you
approach a black hole for rather than
there is this
infinite ratio so so
i won't have time to go go to any other
uh example but uh
you can't you can do this you can you
can
read all the geometry for different
input states
for whatever state you like and you can
you can add a mass to the system which
you see there is a space calculation or
you can use two chains which are
entangled
translate this into two disks in the
bulk which are entangled and you see
that they are entangled
very much uh in the center so in the end
the two space are connected and becomes
the wrong hole
then i see all these uh all these kind
of things and uh
uh so so in general
just one sentence about the general
picture behind this is
as i said earlier the choice of mapping
is sort of like
you choose a classical background to
expand a lot so
so so there is of course ambiguity of
what you choose
so for the scale environment case there
is a sort of uh
given choice then you you calculate the
geometry and then you get
uh you get something with the same
symmetry as this it has a scalar
environment
but uh in general uh in general there is
no priority choice you can make
different choices
and i would say this approach is sort of
like
you start from this classical background
geometry and then
now instead of just looking at the
tensor network which gives you the
geometry
now you can calculate this and this is
like giving you the column corrections
to that geometry
so it may not converge but it gives you
uh to the leading order it tells you
which direction is going
like this this mapping may look like an
ids based but
you have finite temperature it tells you
it's actually a vds visible i call
rather than ideas itself so it tells you
the direction
where the geometry is going okay i think
i will stop there
thank you
yeah um you pick specific quantum from
italian you get
you see heck medics but i mean
asc is like specific methods but like
quantum graphics and metrics should
fluctuate it's like integrated with
respect to all matters yes
all magnets yeah that's a
that's a good question yeah so so as i
said this is like expanding it around
so i'm not so yeah so one thing i should
clarify is
uh is that having having i mean
uh having a way to calculate this metric
and then
compare it with a classical metric like
ideas doesn't mean
this theory this box area of things this
way is the second class of gravity
because the semiconductor gravity will
have gravitons and all these things
right i mean
it's not only about the metric but about
fluctuation away from imaging
here what i have is like um
in this choice of uh you can think of
this as
as my geometry is still strongly
fluctuating
but uh for each geometry this choice of
mapping gives me a way to define the
partition number
so i define for this on the points
on the geometry for each of the
graduating metrics
and then i'm doing my average power in
the measure which gives me an
average of what the geometry
the fact that the bulk has no graviton
because the battery is a free formula
and
when i do this free formula magnet the
bulk is also free for me
so the bug only has three permian so so
you can say there's a signature that
tells you
i mean that will uh require uh
to find the correct boundary theory
maybe we know it may be a serial numbers
but
required to do this for less specific
theory which will give me
uh this einstein in the box and that's
apparently that's the very
that's the most interesting question i
still don't know how to
so so just the reference to your paper
is 30 because
yeah um
dot 6282 1309
628 this is your paper
every time i forgot to give them
zero this would work well um
i yeah i mean uh
but we basically have no much choice
here oh you mean like i can have
different
different powers uh let's say you're
more you know you can
try and take critical points from here
then i'm not sure because
i don't know what to take with you
i mean let's see
i will get the this is like the right rd
but if i now usually just take the
screen and then do this
symmetricalness maybe i'm not sure if
that gives me the
range here
yeah so so far in writing theory i don't
know how to define
k zero
in practice you can think about doing a
mira calculation to optimize
the things that you want to keep so so
so maybe we find the optimize the mirror
and then we ask what is the radio
entanglement between the size
yeah yeah but again we face the problem
that
a correlation function in the block will
involve many sites on the property
so so what i didn't get time to say is
uh i mean then it seems not useful for
interacting system
but i think it may be useful as a
vibrational enzyme right i can
i can put some entangled but very simple
state in the box it's like free from it
and then map this back to the boundary
if i put a direct product state
this keeps being narrow but if i use
some other some preference later on
then it gives me some different state so
so maybe it gives you uh
some different eyesight to describe the
many body systems so i can only think of
that in this very
way it may
maybe let's break and make
got